[Musique]
tu es celui qui exécute les tueurs de
flics je vais les retrouver
combien de policiers
8 le pire carnage juin 18 ans ils
avaient été appelés pour un cambriolage
j'ai choisi c'est pas pour rien je vais
les retrouver
si on choque pas ces types dans les
trois ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront
de quand et où faire il y à 21 points
qui permettent de sortir de manhattan
on monte des barrages
on arrête tous les trains ont toutes les
stations de métro
ensuite on inonde l'île de flics ça pas
de sens le guide s'était 30 kg et on se
retrouve avec trois cents
il se passe quoi la jeu de la vérité
c'est toi
ils m'ont dit que tu étais une tête
brûlée celui qui exécute les tueurs de
fric
personne le coup tu me mets à moi